هذا هو المكان الذي اغتيل فيه لاستاذ
الجامعي عقيل عبد الله من قبل المسلحين
يستقلان دراجه ناريه وهو على مقربه من
منزله ليفارق الحياه بعد نقله الى
المستشفى
مجلس العزاء كسر حزنه التاهب الكبير
للقوات الامنيه والقاء القبض على الجنات
نتقدم بالشكر الجزيل الى قياده شرطه ذي
قار والاجهزه الاستخباريه جميعا لجهودها
المبذوله وملاحقه الجينات والقبض عليهم
الاوساط التعليميه مع زميلهم واستنكرت ما
حدث وحولت المصابه الى تظاهرات تطالب
بالقصاص من القتله وانهاء ظاهره السلاح
المنفلت الذي يستهدف كفاءات العراق
ان قتل دوله اثنين القتلوا اخونا بدون سبب
وعمرنا
لا شايفينه
ابدا فاحنا نطالبهم بالقصاص الالهي قصاص
اول مره حكم الله وثانيا حكم القانون
القانون العراقي يؤكد هذا الشيء 406 القتل
المتعمد
يعني حتى
بعض الفكر وبعد النظام
القوات الامنيه نجحت في القبض على
المتهمين بجريمه في وقت قصير سرعه تحرك
القوات الحكوميه ابقت على الامن والهدوء
الذي عاشته المحافظه منذ شهور دون ان تشوه
صورته هذه الحادثه
لقناتى العربيه والحدث شاكر عواد الناصريه